hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
life is complicated i don't mean your
life my life those are also complicated
but as we all know biology is
complicated the history of biology is
complicated here on mindscape you know
i'm interested in very big questions
like the origin of life but we also have
the evolution of life right that's
interesting all by itself and so
there's a bunch of phase transitions
that we like to talk about that happened
over the course of the evolution of life
one such transition was the origin of
eukaryotes right eukaryotes are cells
that have nuclei in them and we think
these days that that came about from two
different kinds of cells getting
together joining together sharing their
dna
distributing it in the cell in
interesting ways you have mitochondria
and then you have the nuclear dna and
it's all a big part of the interesting
kinds of life we have on earth i
shouldn't say interesting it's all
interesting the complex kinds of life we
have on earth eukaryotes compared to
prokaryotes which don't have nuclei
have a lot more capacity a lot more
potential for being complex such as
being multicellular and once you go from
a single-celled organism to a multi-cell
organism then the possibilities of
complexity grow enormously so today's
guest will ratcliffe is a biologist who
is one of the world's experts on exactly
this transition from unicellularity to
multicellularity
in the evolution of life
not just studying what happens there in
the record of actual life on earth but
doing artificial evolution or what some
people call directed evolution doing an
experiment in the lab where he takes
season to group take yeast cells and
they let them evolve they give a little
bit of selection pressure to grow bigger
and they say you know they don't poke in
their the dna they just let mutations
happen and watch what happens to these
initially
unicellular yeast organisms uh and what
happens very quickly is they become
multicellular you know in some sense
which we'll hopefully try to make clear
in the podcast
yeast and many other eukaryotes are
ready to be multicellular in some sense
so a little nudge uh pushes them in the
right direction but there are surprises
that come up along the way you know
there are different ways to be
multicellular and there's a big
difference between mult being
multicellular in the sense of just
having a lot of cells sticking together
versus being truly differentiated with
different organs and things like that
and even though the experiments have not
been going on very long there's still
thousands of generations that we have
ability to look at and it's taught us
something about this crucially important
transition which might have implications
for you know life elsewhere uh the idea
of life the future of life even now that
we human beings have the ability to to
actually go in there and poke at the
genome of different kinds of organisms
and see what happens you know maybe
there's whole kinds of genetic
information schemes that would lead to
different kinds of organisms that
evolution was not able to find i don't
know i'm just a physicist then podcast
host but will is an expert on this so
let's go
[Music]
will ratcliffe welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you i'm delighted to be
here so multicellularity a big thing in
the history of life uh we it's no
planning on my own part you know i i
don't plan a
series of podcasts in any interesting
way but we have been talking a little
bit about the origin of life recently
did bachelor kachar about uh what we
learned about old life from paleo
genomics and so forth but that was all
single-celled stuff basically so
why don't you put us into context like
when did multicellularity arise what do
we know about its origins
yeah no i'm i'm i'm happy to be on this
sort of path of understanding life's
origin and the evolution of complexity
and in some sense they've already done
the hard work because once you have a
cell you've already sort of you know
you've done 95 percent of that i
actually agree with nigel goldenfeld in
his recent interview where he said you
know once you have cells who cares about
elephants yeah to some extent i agree
with them to the other extent i've made
my entire career on disagreeing with him
so
so multicellularity is is when you have
us an organism that's composed of
multiple cells and and it opens up all
kinds of opportunities for complexity
because those cells can take on
different roles you can get all sorts of
novel ecologies arising and you can have
organisms with all these specialized
functional parts
when multicellularity arose is kind of
not really a it's not this there's no
one one answer because multicellularity
actually has evolved many times in
different lineages on earth
so we actually have anything from like
five times or 500 times
um
in between the two okay
so
it's probably in the in around a hundred
although we actually don't know wow
robust estimate that's a lot though okay
so that's it's a lot some lineages like
the green algae it's evolved more than
25 times independently in just green
algae alone but isn't it true
that
life on earth was
unicellular for a really really long
time
yeah so the majority of like so life you
know start when life started out
pre-cellular and then once you have sort
of it
becoming cellular that's really a sort
of almost a sea change in how
life you know evolves information is
transmitted vertically and you have sort
of cellular revolution
and that was probably on the order of
3.8 billion years ago or even earlier
like that's about the origin of luca the
last universal common ancestor so the
coalescence of of all things can be
traced back to that point but there's
probably some cellular life before that
but it's very very hard to study
anything that's that old
and um
yeah so and the majority the majority of
the diversity of life that we have out
here today is also single-celled um
right but different single-celled
lineages began exploring with
multicellularity at different time
points so cyanobacteria began forming
chains of cells in which you'd have
cells that are specialized for carbon
fixation through photosynthesis or
nitrogen fixation by basically taking
nitrogen from the air and turning it
into ammonium which can be used building
proteins and stuff and that happened
around 2.1 billion years ago
and then you have that's all and
different types of bacteria played
around with multicellularity and between
2 billion and 1 billion years ago and
they've all remained pretty small and
simple then you have eukaryotes arise
and eukaryotes are a special kind of
single-celled organism they're actually
the result of a fusion between a archaea
and alpha proteobacterium that alpha
proteobacterium was at one point a
symbiont and became domesticated as our
mitochondrion to sort of provide energy
for ourselves
and these eukaryotic cells have really
sort of run away with with a with sort
of i don't know uh
forming different kinds of organisms
that bacteria and archaea don't really
seem to be able to form so what they say
there what you just said about the
origin of the eukaryotes the the cells
with with nuclei in them uh you sounded
pretty confident i'm not sure uh from my
own you know naive physicists reading uh
do are are we pretty confident that we
really know how that started and and and
why it started or
getting more and more confident yeah so
there so as we find these uh archaea
from the loki yarkoda and other sort of
asgard related
it's a great acronym right
i don't you know what it stands for but
this there's this clade of archaea um
that have been found in sort of seafloor
sediments in the arctic i guess the near
arctic
and these things have all sorts of
eukaryote-specific cell biology things
that we thought only eukaryotes have
and it turns out that they are archaea
and if you look at them on a
phylogenetic tree which is like a tree
of like like a genealogical tree but
applied to
vast time scales and not just you know
your your local family
um then you can see that they actually
nest as a sister group to eukaryotes so
we're pretty sure that archaea um and
this and if you if you sort of begin to
disentangle and unpack how eukaryotes
arose you really see that we basically
have a that eukaryotic cells have a
mixture of archaeal stuff and bacterial
stuff like our
the lipid membrane that we have
surrounding ourselves is actually
bacterial
okay it's not archaeal they use a
different kind of of chemistry in their
lipids which make the membrane of the
cell and we think that actually came
over from the
um from the mitochondria so the nucleus
was the archaea
and then the big puffy part was the
bacteria or vice versa so we actually i
think those details we don't really know
those are still the kinds of things
we're working out but i think a better
way of thinking about it is that the
cell as a whole like the macros like the
the larger symbiont yeah was the archaea
and that sort of got smaller bacteria
living within it and those bacteria got
sort of co-opted to being a part of this
new eukaryotic cell
they can't divide on their own anymore
they still have a remnant little genome
right so if you look at it inside a
mitochondrion it has its own genome
which is you know one of those things
that made people realize you know 40
years ago oh my gosh like these things
were once free living separate cells
right so this is this is i know probably
a lot of people in the audience know
this very well but maybe there are some
who don't and it's so amazing i really
want to just sit and dwell on it that
there's two different sets of dna in
every one of our cells there's you know
our dna and then there's these little
free writing not free writing but
symbiotic mitochondrial dna uh in every
one of our cells and so we sort of
genetically pass down both from
generation to generation
yeah and the and the and the
dna inside of mitochondria is totally
stripped down like if you imagine that
it was at one point a car now it is just
the steering wheel or i don't know what
the better analogy is but but you know
it's it's you know 20 000
dna bases when a free living bacteria is
typically on the order of a few million
cool so they're just they're teeny yeah
yeah and so in fact most of the dna from
from the uh genome of the mitochondria
has been exported and is now residing
inside our our chromosomes oh okay all
right so we co-opted the the useful
parts of it and there's some of the
useful parts other useful parts are
still hanging out in the mitochondria
yeah certain elements of it it seems
like it's kind of hard to move them into
them through those membranes into the
mitochondria and it's better just to
have them made locally but other stuff
you want top down host control and so
you just move that stuff into the domain
of the host and it was this
you know we love phase transitions here
on the mindstate podcast so this this uh
leap from uh
prokaryoticness to eukaryoticness was a
big phase transition and you're saying
that that enabled new kinds of
multicellularity or made it easier
it certainly seems that way although we
don't have a first principles
you know universally accepted
explanation for why that's true
so when you look at sort of the tapestry
of multicellular organisms there are
bacterial and archaeal multicellular
organisms but they're very very simple
they've been around for a really long
time billions of years and they don't
seem to have really done much beyond
making small groups of cells
within eukaryotes though you have the
entire sort of complex tapestry of life
that you see when you look out your
window right you see trees you see
things growing on those trees you see
insects buzzing around those you see
mushrooms growing off of logs all of
those things are eukaryotic
multicellular organisms
and multicellularity one of the great
features of it is it's like the sort of
anti-anna karenina thing right and
unlike all multi-secular families being
alike in the same way right they are in
fact all very very different every
multicellular lineage does
multicellularity in its own specific way
you know free living um algae in in
ponds that that form spherical colonies
of multicycle cells that spin around
with the flagella that keep the modal
are very different from plants which are
essentially
growing into the air and competing for
light which are very different from
animals which are very different from
fungi so in some sense it's a challenge
to try to come up with universal rules
for understanding how multicellular
organisms evolve and become more complex
on the other hand we actually we can
still do that but but you have to keep
in mind that every lineage has its own
ways of becoming multicellular that
depend on its specific ecology and very
importantly the cell biology of the
ancestor
is it just too simplistic to imagine
that being eukaryotic
provides a bit more flexibility when it
comes to being multicellular in the
sense that a good robust multicellular
organism will each cell has the same dna
but it gets expressed in different ways
and being a eukaryote uh enables sort of
more flavors for that
yeah that's actually you kind of nail
the explanation that people have which
is that eukaryotic cells have a much
larger number of
sort of types of gene regulation
available to them and it's easier to get
cellular differentiation eukaryotes they
also tend to be larger cells with
more complex forms of cellular
morphology
the the ancestors of eukaryotes off
eukaryotes often have like at least if
we look at like that the best work in
this area has been done by people
looking at the unicellular relatives of
animals
okay so animals right evolved roughly
800 million years ago
and you know if you go back to the sort
of family tree just one step above
animals there's things which which you
know are common ancestor of animals and
things which have stayed single cell
and if you look at those things that
have stayed single celled they often
have these complex life cycles where
they can exist as an amoeboid and crawl
around which looks a lot like you know
one of your
blood cells that's going off and trying
to kill pathogens right it can exist as
a flagellated state where it's swimming
which looks a lot like a sperm cell it
can exist in many different sort of
temporal types of cell differentiation
which you could imagine get sort of
reworked from being expressed in time to
express in space and now you have all
these sort of modules to play with for
building a multi-cycle organism yeah and
it's also kind of cool because in some
sense a little bit of complexity at the
micro level is enabling much greater
complexity at the macro level
absolutely
and but but i i just i i want to caution
that this is
consistent with what we understand but i
don't know if it's it's not universally
accepted yet perfectly because bacteria
and archaea are extraordinarily complex
and diverse and it's kind of hard to
find something that eukaryotes can do
that they can't do that makes sense yeah
no that makes perfect sense um so this
was so this transition to eukaryotes was
about 800 million years ago
that was probably more on the order of
about two billion years two billion
years ago okay yeah animals were roughly
800 million years ago i see okay so
eukaryotes
so this story that i was that i have in
mind of uh it taking a long time for
multicellularity
to arise sort of gets divided into it
took a a medium long time to be
eukaryotic and then another medium long
time to be multi-cell either right
that's right yeah so in the eukaryotic
space you know eukaryotes arise around
two billion years ago and then roughly a
billion years later you start to see the
first lineages of like bonafide
eukaryotic multicellular organisms
arising
and still sort of persisting to the to
the modern day so you see
and this really occurs in red and green
algae interestingly enough so you get
these small little algae that form
branched you know topologically
structured like little trees branched
multicellular groups which if you look
at the fossils and look at modern day
ones oh my gosh they look basically the
same yeah
and
this whole story is just uh bizarre to a
physicist because we think of
systems as being characterized by time
scales and if you don't know any better
there's a certain time scale that
governs everything that happens and
presumably the time scale for a
microorganism is you know it's lifetime
or it's time to uh
split or something like that and those
numbers are much much smaller than a
billion years so for some for something
interesting to happen but for it to take
a billion years to happen is is just a
reminder that physics is not very good
at estimating certain things
right and and that the time scales that
things i think something that we we kind
of keep learning in evolutionary biology
is that the potential for something to
evolve in a certain way
is often extreme it's often kind of
unlimited over sort of geological time
scales things can evolve very very very
quickly given suitable selection and
often when you see stasis it's simply
because you don't have
any selection in any you know
significant selection on the organism's
state
and so um during that you know one two
billion years to roughly 540 million
years
before the present you had an era of
very very low environmental oxygen
and so that actually in some ways
changes the expectations of of whether
whether you expect to see multicycle
clarity and what types of multicellular
you expect to see
when you give the charity how much
impact will your donation actually have
this question can be hard if not
impossible to know most charities can't
tell you how your money will be used or
how much good it will accomplish you may
know will theoretically help a cause but
how or more importantly how much
if you want to help people living in
poverty with evidence-based high-impact
charities i recommend you check out
givewell
givewell spends over 20 000 hours each
year researching charitable
organizations and only recommends a few
of the highest impact evidence-based
charities they found and here's the best
part givewell is free givewell wants to
empower as many donors as possible to
make informed decisions about their
donations they publish all of the
research and recommendations on their
site for free no sign up required they
allocate your tax deductible donation to
the charity you choose without taking a
cut if you've never donated to
givewell's recommended charities before
you can have your donation matched up to
250
before the end of the year or as long as
matching funds last
so to claim your match go to
givewell.org pick podcast and enter
mindscape at checkout make sure they
know that you heard about givewell from
mindscape to get your donation matched
well i guess that was going to be that
was going to be my question uh you know
i'm a big fan of multicellular organisms
myself being one but uh from the
evolutionary point of view what was the
benefit to becoming multicellular and
and i guess you've already started
saying something about oxygen
well yeah there's a lot of different
benefits to multicellularity this is
again goes back to the sort of uh
reverse anachronic problem right where
every lineage has its own sort of
reasons to become multicellular so
there's no one sort of reason to do it
in some cases you have organisms that
are forming groups in order to avoid
being consumed by predators because
predators are filter-feeding and they
have a small mouth and if something
bonks against their face and can't get
in their mouth then they're not eaten so
it's good to form a group in other cases
you have organisms that are cooperating
metabolically they're excreting stuff
into the environment and if you can get
a sort of clump of cells that are all
cooperating and excreting enzymes into
the environment you can degrade
environmental stuff much better than if
it's a chimera a chaotic mix of
different species and things that are
maybe not producing the enzymes etc um
there are
there's actually a whole list we're
actually working on a review paper on
this right now i could go on and on but
it doesn't really matter what matters is
that there's lots of different reasons
to come with the cellular maybe one
that's really relevant to algae or
photosynthetic organisms is that you
know light is this very valuable
resource but it's directional so if you
can overgrow your competitors
all right you get the food and that's
why we have you know 300
foot tall trees they're not like getting
more sun by being 300 feet taller than
something sitting on the ground they're
just getting to it first
well they're they're not being uh
overgrown by somebody else right when
you're the tallest one exactly and it's
so it's an arms race right like trees
are the result of a 450 million year
long arms race
but then i'll
let you go into more about the oxygen
stuff because that clearly was relevant
yes yes okay so oxygen is very important
um in the sense that we really see sort
of if you look back at the history of
multicellularity you see these sort of
experiments in in let me just talk about
how oxygen's happened on earth first
the great oxidation event which i think
is a great term very much named by
geologists because it took several
hundred million years for this event to
occur
occurred roughly 2.1 billion years ago
in that in that era a couple hundred
million years you have cyanobacteria
cracking out so much oxygen that we go
from a world that basically is anaerobic
to one that actually has oxygen in the
atmosphere and the oceans
it's but it's a very very low levels
maybe one percent of modern levels may
be lower it's at very low levels and it
stays low for the next
one and a half billion years and then in
the phanerozoic era
which is about 540 million years before
now it starts to really rise and that's
actually concordant with this explosion
in multicellular diversity you have you
know the cambrian explosion in animals
happening right around that time plants
land plants kind of invade not that much
longer right and fungi they've been
around for a while we actually don't
have a great understanding of the origin
and diversification of fungi
but fungi seem to really also diversify
around this time as well
and so
we've long thought that oxygen was this
kind of catalyst for multicellularity
that that if you give so a system oxygen
you're going to enable the evolution of
larger more complex multicellular
organisms and there's a very good
physical reason for this which is that
if cells depend on having oxygen
and you form a group then you become
diffusion limited and those internal
cells don't have access to very much
oxygen and therefore that might set a
maximum size on an organism um because
you know basically if you can't get
oxygen to the interior maybe those cells
can't survive at all that sets a maximum
size to the organism and so until you
can invent a circulatory system you're
stuck with diffusion and therefore size
is just directly a function of oxygen
concentration we've thought this way for
a long time this isn't something we have
actually tested though so a postdoc in
my group ozone bostog did this cool
experiment where he took um
our yeast system maybe this is a good
time to introduce it
well well keep keep talking we'll go
back to the east don't worry all right
good good
in in any case um
although okay you can't explain it
it's hard for me to explain our change
in thinking about oxygen without
referencing the experiment because that
was what what helped us okay this
the point is that uh you know when i
talked to betul we talked about the
great oxygenation event uh two billion
years ago and what you're emphasizing is
that's nothing there's another
growth of oxygen by a factor of 100
later on right and
there's this uh you know it's it's not
completely clear why that happens and
we're going to illuminate maybe why it
happens but talk about yeast so let's
let's pause there and talk about yeast
for a while you know uh what's a yeast
and why do you care about it
so so yeast are single-celled fungus and
i care about them because they're a
really wonderful model organism for
laboratory experiments and we all it's
we're in the middle of pandemic and
everyone is baking bread so we're all
familiar
with yeast but so this is a so it's a
fungus uh which is um
what what kingdom is that in that's a
plant that's a no sorry not a plant it's
a fungus obviously but it's a
eukaryote
it's eukaryote yeah it's yeah eukaryotic
fungus single cell yeah
it's a single sod eukaryote um and they
actually the funny thing about the yeast
yeast is a generic term for any single
cell fungus the yeast that we use is
saccharomyces cerevisiae and so so
there's many different yeasts and
they're they can actually be very very
diverse
uh there's yeast from you know very
different branches of the fungal tree of
life
it actually seems to be a kind of a
common strategy and this is the only
multicellular group that does this where
you'll have things which form
filamentous multicellular fungi they'll
actually evolve to form single-celled
yeast and in fact the yeast that we work
on saccharomyces cerevisiae which is the
baker's yeast it's the most common yeast
used by humanity it's sort of
domesticated by humans for brewing beer
and baking bread
it's also in many ways like
one of the most well studied and
extensively used uh workhorses of
molecular molecular and cellular biology
in the research community and it's it's
very very easy to make it do what you
want you can you can
you know you can basically do crazy
synthetic biology experiments very
easily in yeast because you can just
kind of stick genes in them and they'll
express them and it works
i mean that's clearly very useful and
also i get the impression that you know
even if yeast are unicellular they're
kind of living on the edge of wanting to
be multicellular
i think that's probably true
um certainly in our case our yeast
derived descended from a multi-cellular
ancestor but that was several hundred
million years ago so what does that even
mean during that time they've really
lost
much of their genome that that we know
multicellular fungi have they seem to
have changed jettisoned at all okay so
they devolved inside in some sense yes
yep and this is very rare in the in this
palette of multicellularity you don't
see unicellular descendants of animals
or plants right running around nature
but fungi seem to do this all the time
i see so the yeast you're dealing with
uh were formerly a multicellular
organism and now they like to be
unicellular
yeah they've been unicycling for a long
time
and then you so it's not completely
surprising that you can sort of prod
them in different ways and mutate them
and get them back to being multicellular
yeah it may not be that surprising
though i don't think they're actually
reactivating like latent ancestral
pathways of multicellularity i think
it's actually just pretty easy for them
to
in our case we understand the cell
biology of how they become multicellular
in our lab very well and you can just
break the machinery that normally allows
daughter cells to separate from a mother
cell after they're done grow dividing
and then you just get these tree like
you know grow multicellular you know
groups forming so you're not actually
bringing back to life the multicellular
organism that it used to be you're sort
of creating a different kind of
multicellular yeast
exactly
and these are the snowflakes is that
right
yes so tell us about the snowflakes
okay so about 10 years ago when i was
actually a fifth year grad student um
sort of
i guess avoiding writing up my thesis i
started a classroom
i think you've known them i know them in
my lab now sorry if they're listening to
this
i started a collaboration with mike
travisano at the university of minnesota
um
to basically
we had a coffee chat where we're like
what's the coolest thing we could do in
the lab you know after we discussing
origin of life as being too difficult
for us biologists and we're not chemists
so it's you know we don't know how to do
that like maybe we should play around
with evolving multicellularity and so um
over december i started doing these
experiments selecting on
single cell yeast to form groups and we
did a really simple selection experiment
in the lab and these selection
experiments are kind of like selective
breeding in the way that we have you
know we've domesticated dogs and we've
made wheat and corn from wild relatives
it's basically a selective breeding
experiment the fancy term now is either
experimental evolution or directed
evolution
and so we did this really simple
selection experiment where we took our
yeast and every day you know they they
we dilute them 100 fold into fresh media
those cells grow up and then we put them
through sort of a race to get to the
bottom of the test tube okay
so we give them you know a few minutes
sitting on the bench to get to the
bottom of the test tube and then any of
the ones that are at the bottom the test
tube get transferred to fresh media
everyone else is killed and so this
really incentivizes them to form groups
because groups settle through liquid
media faster than single cell so sorry
just to be clear the
mutations in the dna are completely
natural you're not inducing them but the
selection pressure is what you are
that's the directed in directed
evolution right exactly exactly
and we don't really think necessarily
that settling faster is a reason that
things will become multicellular in
nature although there's recent work out
of omaya dodin's lab showing this for
a relative a unicellular relative of
animals
but
in the way that we think of it is it's
really just a very expedient way to
select on size and that's what all these
sort of lineages that are that are
experimenting with multicellularity are
getting advantages from there has to be
an advantage to size otherwise things
say stay single-celled and like most
lineages stay single-celled some of them
have an advantage of forming groups and
those ones are selected to form groups
and so we're just doing that selection
in a really efficient way you know we
can select on a million clusters in a
few in a few minutes of sitting on the
bench and a 10-second pipette transfer
so you're not i mean alternatively in a
synthetic biology sort of context we
might go in there and remove a bit of
dna a gene and replace it with something
else but you're in this particular case
you're actually just letting a mutation
happen
so in the very first experiments we
didn't know what would happen and we
just you know let we just let these
mutations occur and within a few weeks
these populations had all formed these
beautiful little groups that we call
snowflake yeast we came up with that
term actually because uh they settle
much like sort of snow settling through
the liquid media and they actually have
this cool fractal-like growth form where
if you break off a small branch it's
self-similar to the to the morphology of
the larger group you can imagine that
they're growing as a tree and if you
break off a sort of a small branch of
the tree it looks a lot like the bigger
the bigger overall tree growth form
and also we were in minnesota in
december so there was a lot of snow
around
but you know actually all of our
experiments that we do now we start them
out with using the synthetic approach to
basically delete a gene that that was
the one that was most often mutated in
the natural experiments at the beginning
of our to start our experiments off we
just remove that bit of dna to make them
all snowflakes in the same way and then
we can basically re play
multiple parallel runs of our
experiments but they're all starting out
in exactly the same multi-cycle state
these simple ancestral snowflakes but is
it safe to say that it's just one gene
you have to remove to make a unicellular
yeast into a snowflake i mean that get
there's evidence that it's right there
on the edge of being ready to be
multiplied
yeah it's super easy but it's that's
probably true for most unicycle
organisms okay oh okay so
yeah you know we've played around with
algae and and doing similar experiments
in chlamydomonas which is a model green
alga it's also very easy to form groups
and you can do similar things with
bacteria and get them to form chains and
because basically cell division has to
be done correctly in order to get one
cell to pop off a daughter cell and have
them both separate and there's a lot of
ways to kind of break that division
process in a way that gives you a simple
group of cells so yeah so basically it's
very similar to being unicellular but
you're sticking together literally
sticking together
exactly like i think of them as naive
like they are not multicellular
organisms they're a dumb clump of cells
right okay and in fact to become a
multicellular organism is an
evolutionary transformation
okay and uh do these at all
they must occasionally appear in nature
if that's the case like you must get a
mutation that uh creates a yeast
snowflake
i mean certainly they do uh this has
mutation rates fairly fairly high
but we don't typically see them floating
around uh you know on on rotting fruit
or in the the sap of oak trees which is
where you typically find saccharomyces
in its natural habitat you don't really
find snowflakes and i think the reason
for that is that's ecologically costly
for them in this environment if you're
you know if you're making a living as a
yeast and basically being moved from one
sugar source to another dispersal is is
a premium virtue right and if you and
you know your next eight generations of
offspring are all stuck together in one
big group and and a fly doesn't come
down and pick you up on its foot and
transfer you you're dead so it's every
cell phone itself basically reverse bed
hedging okay
and uh okay good are we then ready to
talk about the oxygen the role of oxygen
why was helpful yeah
yep so so our lab uh specializes in
using experimental evolution to study
key steps in the evolution of
multicellularity and multicellular
complexity
and our main model system are these
snowflake yeast
so
getting back to oxygen like looking at
the tapestry of oxygen on the history of
earth we know that it sort of went from
zero to maybe one percent two billion
years ago stayed very low for the next
billion and a half years and then it
smashed up to modern levels around 500
million years ago
and we've long thought that sort of
oxygen was this fuel for the
multicellular fire that that because it
diffuses more deeply into tissues
the size of a of a simple multicellular
organism without a uh without a
circulatory system is just dependent on
the concentration of oxygen in the
environment and therefore you have this
sort of monotonic dependence as you add
more oxygen you get bigger organisms
and but but no one's really ever tested
this and there's a couple reasons but
one of them is that we haven't had a
model system that we could evolve
of multicellularity something which we
could put through 1000 generations or
more in the lab and actually explore its
evolution we haven't had a model system
where we can
toggle the way that they use oxygen
because this actually turns out to be
very important
if you assume that the cells in your
organism all have to use oxygen to grow
well then you sort of really limit the
you you you put an assumption into the
system that's very much going to dictate
the outcome which is if you say if you
don't have any oxygen that cell dies
well then you really restrict them to
being to being small when there's not
much oxygen but it turns out that the
ancestral state of eukaryotes were
called mixotropes that is they could
ferment without oxygen when they had
fermentable carbon or they could switch
over to using you know mitochondria to
respire when there was oxygen available
and that's a pretty sensical strategy in
a world where oxygen is very very low
you don't want to be an obligate arab if
there's not much oxygen in the world so
just to again to sort of linger on this
because it's kind of cool um
so since there is oxygen if there is
oxygen in the world
respiration is a useful way to bring
energy to your internal cellular
workings and the alternative you're
saying is fermentation which again
that's right a lot a lot of alcohol
related uh terminology here but what
exactly is fermentation in this context
fermentation is is just a metabolic
strategy in which you break apart carbon
you know polymers and you get some
energy out of that okay but you don't
you don't use oxygen to sort of burn
them so before there was a survey of
oxygen you could get energy from
fermentation if there was enough oxygen
it's more efficient to just do
respiration
yeah so oxygen provides two huge
benefits one you can get a lot more
energy out of the out of the resource up
to 18 times more energy you know it's so
it's you can get a lot more out of it
yeah and two
some kinds of carbon compounds cannot be
fermented but they can be respired so
it's in that sense it's kind of a
co-factor in letting you eat something
that if you don't have the oxygen you
can't eat it okay which is actually true
for getting back to
you know alcohol you know yeast can eat
alcohol but they need oxygen to do it
so when you're when you're making your
beer people have the airlock on there
and they're trying not to let oxygen get
into their into their you know fermenter
and that's because they don't want the
yeast to eat their alcohol
got it
[Laughter]
when you finally got the right answer
the stars align and the numbers add up
the fastest way to reach your potential
is with the right people in place if
you're hiring you need indeed
indeed is a hiring partner that gets you
what you really want a short list of
quality candidates as fast as possible
because you can do it all attract
interview and hire all at indeed so you
don't have to struggle on your own to
find quality candidates indeed we'll
help you hire the right people right now
and indeed we'll partner with you on
every step of the hiring process so you
can find talent with the skills you need
through tools like indeed instant match
assessments and virtual interviews get
started right now with a 75 sponsored
job credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through december
31st terms and conditions apply need to
hire you need indeed
okay good so i'm sorry i interrupted you
talking about the usefulness of the
oxygen to the east okay yeah so so what
we have is a question how does the
evolution of multicellular size depend
on the presence of oxygen we've had this
long assumption that it's monotonic that
you the more oxygen you give them the
bigger they can get
and we have now this this yeast model
system where we can evolve them in the
lab and we can we can go through about
five generations of evolution per day so
you know in a year you're
you know over a thousand generations
it's you can really push push their
evolution fast and we can select on size
very easily and then we can actually
mess with yeast yeast or a great model
organism and we can basically make them
fermentation only so we can basically
make them anaerobic and we do that by
basically breaking their mitochondria
they have mitochondria we can break them
yeah okay the mitochondria don't work
anymore they can only ferment then we
can actually we can make them respire
only so they can only grow using oxygen
or we can let them do both we can let
them be their the native state of yeast
actually is to be a mixatrift just like
the native the ancestral state of
eukaryotes they can either ferment or
respire depending on what that cell
wants to do
so we took all three of these different
kinds of snowflake yeast which were
otherwise identical at the start of the
experiment and we evolved them with
selection for larger size
and we didn't get what we expected we
expected that the more oxygen they had
oh and and i should say we also did this
um with with
different environmental oxygen so we
gave them low environmental oxygen or
high environmental oxygen and we gave
them high by basically just bubbling
that stuff through through their tubes
so so there's a lot going on here but
what happens is when we evolve them
what we find is that
unlike the expectation that the more
oxygen they have the bigger they get
we find that when they have no oxygen
that is they're an anaerobe or they have
a low amount of oxygen it doesn't matter
if they're a mixotroph or an obligate
aerobe or they have high amounts of
oxygen right we end up getting this nike
swoosh it's not a monotonic increase
they get really big when they have no
oxygen they evolve to be really big when
they have lots of oxygen and when oxygen
is limiting they actually stayed small
didn't really get very much bigger at
all despite a thousand generations of us
every day selecting for bigger and
bigger sizes but is it only the
fermenters that get big when there's no
oxygen
so actually that's how we make gave them
no oxygen rather than removing oxygen
from the test tubes we just remove their
ability to use it
so the fermenters are essentially in the
no no oxygen world in our experiment
okay and those guys got big
the ones which could use oxygen if they
had a little bit of oxygen they were
actually much smaller than the
fermenters but if we pumped in tons of
oxygen to their test tubes then they
became very large
so what does that imply for us about
the evolutionary history you're saying
that you know as oxygen increases
first it gets worse for the yeast if we
sort of anthropomorphize a little bit
and think that getting bigger is good
right yeah it indicates a healthy kind
of unicellular yeast uh as oxygen
comes into the atmosphere it's initially
bad is that a safe conclusion
yeah but first let me say rather than
saying bigger is healthier i would say
that bigger is necessary for evolving
complexity okay
it provides opportunities for cells to
evolve different roles and functions and
in fact uh andy noel has has written
very persuasively that size itself is a
driver of increased complexity like once
you have a big organism now you really
have an incentive to evolve a
circulatory system and mechanisms of
cellular communication and resource
transport within the organism so so
science probably came first and
complexity probably followed okay which
is one reason that we're so interested
in science but there is this is a
provocative statement so there is a
chicken and egg problem um is it that
once the cells get big
they
want or need to be complex so they can
differentiate or is it that once the
cells get big they have the capacity to
become complex and that's intrinsically
useful
i would say neither i would say once the
once the groups get large there is an
evolutionary incentive
to evolve the kinds of behaviors that
drive increased complexity okay so they
don't necessarily want to there's no
internal you know desire and a yeast
cluster or you know a clump of cells in
nature
but
there is an advantage associated with
that kind of differentiation once you
have size because once you have size you
have all of these diffusion limitations
that make that make growth very
difficult and also it provides
advantages right you have the
opportunity for an inside outside
environment you know you can localize
food to being in the center of your
organism and therefore it doesn't leak
out i mean there's there's all sorts of
reasons why once you have a big group
there are advantages to
evolving essentially the kinds of
interactions and integration amongst the
cells in the organism that typically
drive increased complexity okay and so
then getting back to the evolutionary
history it sounds like we're on the
verge of saying that the first great
oxygenation event
didn't really help because a little bit
of oxygen slows you down but but once it
went way up then it became beneficial
from this is what your yeast uh
experiments are teaching us then it
became essential to become more muscular
that's exactly right that at first we
probably would have been better off
without the great oxidation event and in
fact geologists call that period of time
between two billion years and one
billion years ago the quote-unquote
boring billion right
because you know there's not that much
happening in the biosphere that's at
least apparent in the geological record
i'm sure there's all sorts of really
interesting you know single-celled
microbial biochemistry and evolution
happening
but you don't see that really in the in
the fossil record
and so during that sort of you know low
oxygen boring billion oxygen may in fact
have acted as a constraint and i'll just
throw one more thing in there the reason
why we think that we got this nike
swoosh effect is not just artifacts of
metabolism or some or some sort of you
know short-term um
proximate explanation but we actually
built an evolutionary model to
understand this effect better and it
turns out that if you build a very
simple first principles model then you
can recapitulate this behavior and it's
extraordinarily robust and the intuition
actually is that
oxygen is a valuable resource
and so if you have no oxygen well
there's nothing to compete for if you
give a system a little bit of oxygen
well now all of a sudden those groups
that can better utilize that oxygen have
an advantage in fact that provides an
incentive to get smaller and have a
larger proportion of the cells in that
group be capable of utilizing that
oxygen to grow faster to divide more
they they tend to win in these
evolutionary simulations and then as you
despite their lower survival because
we're always saying bigger provides
better survival right despite their
lower survival they still win by getting
smaller but then you pump in enough
oxygen to the system that they can both
get big and have high survival and use
the oxygen well and there's no longer a
conflict they don't have to get small to
use the oxygen and that's really what we
think is driving this suppression of
multicellular size from oxygen but small
amounts effectively saying like here's a
valuable resource but if you're big you
don't get to use it very well and so
that's a very strong selective incentive
to get smaller or stay small and you can
remove that by removing oxygen entirely
or pumping tons of it into the system so
one of the lessons that i got from
talking to batula was uh
these transitions that have a big effect
on life like oxygen
there's a give and take right uh there's
sort of geological or even astrophysical
things that happen that change
conditions on earth that that
make the environment for the living
organisms different but then living
organisms feed back in quite an
impressive way to what is going on on
earth so can we say something about
which is more important for this second
big boost in oxygen was it that life
made more oxygen photosynthesis or was
it something more geochemical going on
i am not the expert on this i would
defer to somebody like chris reinhard
who really studies this problem but my
understanding of it that's kind of a
layman's understanding is that it's a
combination of the two that you had big
changes in earth's temperature you had
snowball earth occurring at about that
time you have big changes in the
composition of the oceans being
bacterial dominated to algal dominated
you have sort of these combination of
biotic and
global geochemical cycles occurring
which combined
drove this transition to far higher
atmospheric oxygen concentrations okay
good
good all right so here we are um how
long ago again
we started these experiments in the very
beginning about 10 years ago i mean how
many how many millions of years ago was
this
was the sorry sorry
was uh was which one was the the the
more oxygenation creating multicellular
life
yeah about 500 500 million years ago
okay
so um more oxygen and
at least if not multicellularity then at
least growth in the size of the
unicellular organisms would be expected
by then and as you as you've made the
case already this uh
is a good allower or it opens the
floodgates to becoming uh multicellular
in interesting ways so did the act we
know did the actual
yeast like the fungi you're looking at
become multicellular or is it is it uh
other things that did
you mean around 500 million years ago a
million years ago yeah that's so that's
the time period in which in which i
think there's sort of a flowering a
renaissance of multicellularity around
the world now to be clear i think a lot
of things had already been multicellular
but they were kind of
largely small sort of unimpressive
things you wouldn't really notice you
know animals probably evolved to form
small multicellular groups 800 million
years ago but it wasn't till about 550
million years ago that there's just this
huge explosion in animal diversity you
know land plants didn't really begin to
colonize uh colonized land and and you
know begin this arms race of getting
larger and more complex until around 450
million years ago
and in terms of like the seaweeds for
example the seaweeds like red algae
and green algae they had been around
since over a billion years ago but those
are very small and you really see this
explosion in seaweed diversity in size
around the same time and then the brown
algae like the dominant kelps that you
see if you go to the ocean and look at
you know look at the look of the sand
that's covered with these big brown kelp
those actually are kind of the most
recent
kid the the new kid on the multicellular
block they evolved roughly 200 million
years ago and we don't really have that
much evidence of what their actual
ancestor looked like despite the fact
that that's one of the most recent
multicellular transitions i'm so glad
i'm not a biologist it's just too
complicated i don't know how you keep
the different colors of algae
in in mind but
but good um this might be a slight
digression but maybe it's exactly the
right time to talk about the fact that
not only do the sizes and stickiness of
your cells and your yeast change but the
shapes uh change as well and you've done
interesting work on sort of the physics
behind packing cells together and
statistical mechanics and things like
that so
it's always important to remember that
as organisms evolve it's not just
changing the genome and giving
yourselves new capacities there's real
physics constraints here that shape what
is possible and what is not
that's totally true and i think that's
it's true for everything and it's very
it's it's maybe more true than than on
almost any other biological system that
i know of for the early evolution of
multicellularity in the sense that you
know forming a group of cells requires
these simple multicellular organisms to
construct to confront
stresses that act over length scales
that they have no history of dealing
with
they're used to dealing with stresses
that act over a few microns they're not
used to stresses that act over 50
microns 100 microns they're not used to
dealing with with avoiding how cell
packing causes strain to accumulate in
groups and causes them to fracture so so
understanding how multicellular
organisms evolve it's not just a
question of biology and understanding
cellular differentiation and gene
regulation and all these things that
biologists tend to think about but it's
also a question of how
multicellular bodies become these sort
of biophysically tough robust structures
so in a sense you can think of this
through the lens of sort of darwinian
materials
okay that a body is a darwinian material
and it's something which evolves and
started out pretty bad and gets good and
how do they do that right
we kind of understand how modern
organisms make you know strong tough uh
bodies
but
they probably do it very differently
from from the way that nascent
multicellular organisms would have done
it because modern organisms are
essentially built through a pattern a
process of development which can take
physical strain into account which can
minimize which can optimize cell packing
in a way that that reduces strain
accumulation it's all coordinated
early multicellular organisms they don't
have this coordination so how do they do
it right uh and so this is a long time
collaboration with peter juncker who's a
soft matter biophysicist georgia tech
um and
we recently have a we put a paper on the
archive with ray goldstein who's at
cambridge
looking at the statistical mechanics of
cell packing in multicellular organisms
now we focused really on just two
moderate model organisms to do our
experiments in number one snowflake
yeast which is a dumb clump of cells at
this point we're talking you know
essentially the origin the original
snowflake yeast it hasn't evolved yet
for any appreciable amount of time in
the lab
and also a green algae volvox which you
may have seen pictures of this in
various textbooks or just online they
form this cool sphere of cells where the
the entire center it's like a marble of
extracellular matrix and the cells are
actually located around the on the
surface okay
so
we thought about sort of what are the
fundamental properties of a simple group
of cells right multicellular organisms
really differ
if noise arises during growing growth
and development that can be catastrophic
to an organism we sort of know how
existing organisms do it but we don't
know how how nascent ones do so we
looked at the distribution of cell free
volumes within these clusters and the
reasoning for that the logic was that
despite the fact that multicellular
organisms are all very different
you know they can have cells growing
like a tree or they can have cells on
the surface of a sphere of extracellular
jelly
they all share one thing in common which
is that cells take up space and if you
sort of go back to what we understand
about the packing of
materials like sand grains or something
it turns out that you get universal
packing statistics for things where
their particles take up space and in
fact this arises from
maximum entropy considerations and the
distribution of cell free volumes or the
amount of free space around each
particle is distributed with a k gamma
distribution and that's that's fact
indicative of a sort of this maximum
entropy uh driven cell packet you'll
have to explain what a k gamma
distribution is
i think you're probably i'm not a
physicist so you're probably the best
better place to explain that
i actually don't know that specific one
but basically what you're saying is that
there's some probability distribution
over different uh ways you can arrange
yourself and it's like some power law or
something like that and it's predictable
based on saying given the macroscopic
constraints let's maximize our entropy
exactly if every possible configuration
of cell packing were equally probable
you would get a distribution of cell
packings that that is very in fact quite
likely
and not a very unlikely distribution um
based on just this very simple
assumption where there's no free
parameter fitting you just need to know
a few things about your system and you
can you can get a predicted distribution
of cell packings based on based on this
assumption
and what does that have to do with the
is well sorry i guess what i should say
is
yeah are the differences between
different kinds of macroscopic
morphologies mostly down to the shape of
the individual cells or is it the
stickiness of the cells with each other
or something more complex i think the
biggest difference has to do with how
the cells arrange themselves in the
group
so there's a sort of there's a sort of
palette of different ways that
multicellular groups can form you can
have trees arising where essentially
daughter cells bud from a mother cell
and remain attached so you can imagine
that you know you're adding ping pong
balls onto existing ping pong balls and
you just continue percolating the growth
of this group right
or you can have something where you have
a sea of cells and you know sphere a
spherical group and the cells are
arranged on the surface or you can have
cells that are sticky actually sticky
and come aggregate together into a big
blob because they're you know they're
attractive to each other
or you can have something where you know
you have one cell that gets really big
and then undergoes a series of repeated
smaller and smaller divisions until it
forms a group of nested cells within a
sort of extra exterior cell wall all of
these things actually occur in nature
as routes to multicellularity one of the
one of the cool things about the
cellularity is that it's very very
diverse
and when we looked at the snowflake
yeast which is basically a brand new
model organism that's had no time to
adapt to being multicellular it's not
even really a multicellular organism
it's a dumb clump of cells and we look
at volvox which have been around for 200
million years and have development on
our a very bona fide multicellular
organism
they both fit this maximum entropy
distribution really really well
and then if we simulate the growth of
different groups according to those four
different things that i just described
we can you know we can we can grow them
through different rules and look at them
and then you know partition space they
all fit this maximum entropy
distribution very very well
and this is cool it's cool for a couple
of reasons number one it tells us that
there's so sort of a multi-sector ground
state that if you're going to form a
group of cells the distribution of
cyclic packing is probably going to be
predicted by this maximum entropy
prediction
and um
you can probably get away from that to
summit to some degree with with
coordinated multicellular development
but it's a starting point
okay and number two it helps us
understand i think one of the larger
conceptual challenges in understanding
how multicellularity arises which is it
helps us understand how groups of cells
get
heritable
traits
even without multi-cellular
developmental programs maybe i should
unpack that a little bit yes i mean this
is exactly where i wanted to go because
let's phrase it in the following way um
as i understand the snowflake yeast
they're multicellular in the sense that
you got a bunch of cells and they're
sticking together
to make a big snowflake kind of shape
but it's not the kind of
multicellularity that we're familiar
with in the macroscopic world where
there's huge cell differentiation and
there's organs and things like that even
though the underlying dna is the same
and so that's even if you say okay i've
made a transition to multicellularity
there's this other big transition
looming in front of us about how you
have cell differentiation within what
you would call an organism and and that
raises the question of what even counts
as a true multicellular organism
right and and i'm going to sidestep the
philosophical discussion here unless you
want to have it because it can take
about 10 minutes
um we'll come back to it but yeah do the
biological first yeah so
i think the way to think about
multicellularity is that forming a group
of cells gives you a multi-cellular
group but it's not a multi-sector
organism right
and
you know in order for something to be an
organism you need to sort of have
there's actually a philosophical
literature on what counts as an organism
and it kind of boils down to you know
the organism contains interacting
components in which you know there's
essentially
mutual adaptation and a client you know
and essentially functionality like so
those elements are baked into what an
organism is
and in order to and essentially the way
i like to think about multicellularity
is that in order to get all these
complex features which is frankly why we
care about multicellularity if
multicellularity was just
little clumps of cells like we wouldn't
really we'd be talking about biofilms we
wouldn't be talking about right
multicellular organisms so in order to
to get those features that make
multicellularity
so rich as a mod as a system uh to have
the sort of power to change the planet's
biosphere which which it did
um you need you know these dumb clumps
of cells to evolve to become more
complex and therefore
it this is actually becomes a
evolutionary description where these
clumps of cells actually gain these
increased features across generations
via darwinian evolution
and so that means that groups of cells
actually need to
essentially have the properties of a
darwinian entity and the cool thing
about a darwinian entity is that it's an
algorithm this applies to anything
living or non-living you only need a few
things to be true in order to have in
order to have a population of things
evolve uh
via darwinian evolution
so you need to have you know whatever
entity it is replicate
it needs to have variation amongst
different entities that variation needs
to be at least somewhat heritable
and their their success either their
ability to reproduce or survive their
persistence in the population their
frequency in the population needs to
depend on those traits that are varying
inheritable and if you have all those
things met then your population will
evolve right essentially if selection is
acting on a trait and it's heritable
then your population will change over
time to have more of that trait that's
true for single cells it's true for ants
it's true for dogs it's true for
chemistry it's true for computer
programs this is just this is just a
feature of the world right it's a
logical argument
and so in order for a multicellular
group to have those properties right
you need to have some way that that
group
reproduces and makes more groups it
needs to have variation in multicellular
traits that variation needs to be
heritable and selection needs to act on
those multicellular traits and if those
properties are true then over
generations you can see those
multicellular groups evolving and in
fact over long periods of time i think
that's how complexity arises
okay but um
i i think i'm on board with everything
you just said
um
but
i i think it's sort of i guess that's a
high level description of what we want
to happen uh is there a sort of
nitty-gritty description of at what
point uh you go from a snowflake where
basically if i understand the snowflakes
every cell is identical you know it's
just except for except for the location
in the snowflake but so at some point
there has to be
um a way of saying no you become this
kind of cell and you over there become
that kind of cell is that very far away
from where we are now uh no i think
that's already happening actually oh
okay
yeah um but it took you know uh
thousands of generations of laboratory
evolution to get to that point
well i mean maybe this is a a good point
to be a little bit more explicit about
the long-term evolution experiment
sure yeah
so about five years ago in my lab ozone
bostock a staff scientist in my group
set up this cool experiment where we'd
actually been trying for years to figure
out how to do a long-term yeast
evolution experiment for you know
selecting on a multicellular trait
and we had kept we kept running into
these problems where they basically
would they would evolve to get larger
and then they plateau and then they just
sit there for you know half a year and
nothing was changing and we're getting
ready to throw up our hands and think
maybe maybe this is not a darwinian
system maybe it doesn't have the
properties that i just described
and then he actually started playing
around with these oxygen experiments
which is actually led to a key
breakthrough which is that it turns out
that we've been doing all of our
experiments in a low oxygen environment
and that oxygen was constraining our
system so they just could there was no
advantage to getting larger and so it
was pegging it at a small size
so we redid the system with
anaerobic yeast so yeast would not with
no functional mitochondria with aerobic
yeast and with mixotrophic yeast and we
did this thing where we grew them every
day and we you know we basically let
them sit on the bench and we took the
ones that got to the bottom and transfer
them to fresh media and we did that you
know every day we've been doing it now
for over a thousand transfers which is
around 5000 generations
and we
kind of escalated the the rate the
length of the strength of settling
selection so now we're only letting them
settle for 10 seconds so they just fall
like rocks at the bottom of the tube
otherwise they're killed
and
over this time we saw the evolution of
snowflake keys that are visible to the
naked eye so they're they're macroscopic
they're bigger than a fruit fly
and this is this was pretty surprising
because it required um so so number one
this this already tells us just
connecting to what i was talking about
this already tells us that they are
that they are a darwinian entity right
that they have these properties in order
to allow them to evolve because they're
getting
tens of thousands of times larger than
their ancestors and we can actually
freeze we freeze our populations in a
minus 80 deep freezer
about every 50 generations and so we can
we can actually go back and pull out our
living fossil record so we know exactly
how they're changing we can compete
existing organisms with any of their
ancestral time points at any time that
we want we can sequence them we know
what all the mutations are
are we know what many of them are doing
not all of them but but a large number
of them we can really understand the
system and we can understand the
biophysics of how these guys evolve to
get big
and so so there's a lot of different
routes that we could take in the
discussion at this point we could talk
about
we just sort of talked a little bit
about the how physics informs the origin
of heredity so maybe it's a good time to
sort of touch back to that and then we
can talk about the physics of how they
evolve these bigger much tougher bodies
well first i just want to mention you
know it's
we're all familiar with selective
breeding right we make different breeds
of dogs and things like that and am i
right to say that the difference here is
uh you're you're not
being that selective like you have a
single thing you're doing you're letting
things fall to the ground but you're not
sort of
fiddling in a kind of uh interventionist
way with like this yeast versus that
yeast you know it's basically you put
them in a harsh environment and watch
them evolve according to their own
lights not because you're pre-selecting
some kind of traits
that's a really really good point in
fact people in the field often make the
distinction between artificial selection
where you would be looking for a
specific trait and picking those
individuals and they'd be constituting
the next generation or sort of
experimental evolution in the lab where
you have a selective scheme that you're
imposing but you are letting them figure
out the traits and phenotypes and things
that sort of you know best optimize
fitness in that environment you're just
letting them run and it's definitely the
latter right we we are not uh picking
winners and and we should give some
credit to the inspiration from richard
lenski's long-term evolution experiment
that's that's entirely why we're doing
this i don't think we would have even
had the thoughts so explain this what
that is
you know they tell the audience what
that experiment was yeah so rich lenski
is um
in many ways the the sort of founder of
the field of experimental evolution and
he has this incredible long-term
experiment in e coli it's been going on
now for
maybe almost 80 000 generations i know
it's between 75 000 and 80 000 and so
it's by far the longest running
continuous evolution experiment
and it's been going for 30 years and and
so you know throughout this this
really unique data set we've learned a
lot of fundamental things about the way
evolution works because you just you
can't look at any other system in nature
and look at
so many generations in this exact same
environment yeah you know we've learned
that basically adaptation never stops
it's a power law
it doesn't asymptote uh you know we've
learned cool things about how novel gene
function arises we've learned cool
things about just basic microbial
evolution we've learned cool things
about
the origin of maintenance of diversif
diversified microbial strategies uh and
because he's done this in 12 replica
populations we've learned a lot about
chance and you know sort of uh necessity
in the process of evolution
and so you you of course um in your
version of the experiment
i mean number one i should say
kudos because this is clearly a very
long-term commitment
for a lab or for a person or whatever
and you have to keep it up right i mean
you can't just like leave it seven days
a week seven days a week you still take
off holidays
someone's gotta be in the lab
and
the difference being that you have a
a window onto this multicellular
transition presumably whereas uh lenski
is looking at just he's stuck with a
unicellular e coli that are evolving in
their own ways
yeah that's right i think that's one of
the really exciting things about our
experiment is that you know we are doing
we are in year three of of 30 or so
and
and i i do i really and i agree it's
it's hard work
really hats off to ozone for for being
you know this completely consistent
utterly committed scientist who has come
in you know 1000 days in a row to do
these experiments we really don't like
to pause the experiment if we can help
it because it throws off the dynamics of
the way that the populations are
evolving well i was just going to ask is
it even possible in principle to pause
it can you just like put everything in
the freezer and come back okay yeah
exactly and we've had to do it several
times you know
you know the incubator overheats and
everything dies or you get contamination
and you have to go back to a time point
but those things happen but we try to
minimize it because actually the
population dynamics are
are really interesting and take days to
re-establish and really non-trivial
especially when you get large groups
that have different probabilities for
survival stuff like that and are you
also doing sort of
separate parallel versions of it to see
differences in ways things can evolve
so we have basically 15 evolving
populations okay five of which can't use
oxygen so five are replicates of a
genotype that started out with broken
mitochondria anaerobics five of which
are mixotropes and five of which are um
obligate arabs and are they all in the
same environment are they different
environments they're all in the same
environment okay
yep and are you hopeful that someday uh
the ones that can't use oxygen will
discover how to is that something to i
don't think so in fact if you if we
sequence them you look at their
mitochondrial genome and uh
it's all gone except for a few origins
of replication so they are like they
give their own oxygen you know an order
of magnitude more mitochondrial genomes
but they are several orders of magnitude
smaller
right i mean this is really pretty much
their mitochondria are gone it's one of
the issues with evolution right is that
it it
generally proceeds by small steps so if
there's a place you could imagine
getting to uh
that would be better for you
but the only route to get there is
through a valley that is worse for you
evolution will roughly speaking never
get you there that's right that's right
that's that's why horizontal gene
transfer can be you know very powerful
and that you can bring in things yeah
totally different lineages and
actually that's the reason that
synthetic biology i think has potential
to do really cool things that you
wouldn't expect to evolve yeah um
because you would have never been able
to put these things together either
valley crossing or just moving machinery
from one disparate lineage into another
finally some intelligent design after
you know it's been thought about for
hundreds of years okay so uh good so
what you were you wanted to say with
that on the ground uh on the table uh
something about the physics of uh what
we're doing
okay so in order so we're selecting for
larger size and again over
i guess i should say our listeners can
take a look at our pre-print to read
about this work it's on the bio archive
or if you just find my twitter thrid
twitter feed uh just google my name will
ratcliffe um
they i sort of walked through the paper
in that twitter thread so you don't have
to read a scientific paper to sort of
see what we're doing but it actually has
a bunch more cool visuals
i can link to both of my show notes so
people should check them out on
preposterousuniverse.com yeah
excellent show notes perfect
so um
over the course of five thousand you
know generations of experimental
evolution uh the anaerobic yeast evolved
to get you know 20 000 times bigger than
their ancestor the aerobic and
myxotrophic yeast which can use oxygen
are actually pegged just a few times
bigger than their ancestor so you know
we've selected on them for five thousand
generations they don't do anything in
terms of size
which is kind of neat it's a i think
it's a nice
follow-up to the oxygen work that i
mentioned before a nice long-term
evolution experiment so the anaerobes
they've gotten huge
and we actually know a lot about the
physics of how um
of how multicellular groups uh grow to a
certain size how snowflakes grow to a
certain size before they break and it
turns out that fracture in this case is
driven by
cells dividing into the interior of the
group causing packing a strain
accumulating from cell cell packing and
when that straining accumulating uh from
packing exceeds the strength of a cell
cell connection you break a branch and
much like cutting a branch off a tree
when you break a branch of a snowflake
it floats away and that's actually cool
because connecting to the darwinian
algorithm argument i talked about before
this is a way that one group can make
multiple groups as it grows it breaks
off branches those branches then grow
back to approximately their parent size
they begin to break and you get this you
know sort of life cycle and there's
actually been a fair amount of work
devoted to understanding how
multicellular life cycles arise and i
think this physical packing causing
strain mechanism is extremely simple one
it's robust it gives a very nice life
cycle and it does something which is
actually very important in the context
of biology here it introduces genetic
bottlenecks
if you imagine that like you know you
have a branch of cells where imagine
it's sort of like you have a ping-pong
ball and you put a ping-pong ball on the
top of it and each of those cells has a
new ping pong ball on top of it and then
all of them get another ping pong ball
popped off
that bottom ping pong ball is the sort
of parent of everything downstream right
it's the progenitor cell and it's you
know three generations back but it's the
progenitor cell so if you take if you
imagine that that's actually just a
branch in a bigger snowflake and you
were to break that branch off then that
cell at the base of that branch is
actually the genetic parent of
everything downstream so as mutations
arise within these branches and you
break the branches you're actually
segregating genetic variation between
groups
that actually turns out to be profoundly
important
for
allowing mutations to arise
which change the properties of cells
which have emergent properties that
change the properties of groups and
selection can act on the groups
themselves but because all the cells in
the group have the same genotype they
have the same mutation now there's a
statistical correlation between the
group level trait and a genetic trait in
the cells and so if you select on that
emergent group trait well they also
there's an underlying genetic basis and
now you can actually drive continued
darwinian evolution
so this is though um
not what we see in cell differentiation
in
big
organisms where the underlying dna is
all the same but they're just expressed
differently this is true
uh genome differentiation between
different parts of the snowflake and
then maybe a part can break off and
really be a different kind of organism
i think the way that i would uh sort of
compare this to extant organisms is that
this is similar to having mutations in a
fertilized egg
and so or like in a lineage of cells
that leads up to a fertilized egg and so
the egg is now the bottleneck that
entire organism develops with the same
genetic under basis
and so you know in any organism that has
single cell propagules you have a
bottleneck proper in our organism you
don't have single cell propagules but
you have these branches that actually
act kind of in the same way
that it basically and in fact you can
calculate like the maximum waiting time
for genetic variation to be partitioned
between groups and it's not very long it
sort of sets up an expectation that
sooner or later any mutation that arises
will be partitioned off into its own
group and then you'll never have
admixture between that group and another
group again so it's a one-way direction
towards breaking up you know mutations
that arise within an organism and making
it
between organisms and then is there
competition in the test tube between the
different yes it's an arms race just
like the trees getting taller as an arms
race in our case we don't we don't
transfer all of the clusters that
survive in a given set of time like 30
seconds of sinking we only transfer the
bottom of the group of cells that are
racing to the bottom and so there's a
continual arms race dynamic here where
it's not good enough just to get to the
bottom in 10 seconds or 30 seconds
you've got to beat everyone else trying
to get to the bottom in 30 seconds have
you ever read the short story by
theodore sturgeon called microcosmic god
no
oh you should
it's from many decades ago but it's
basically uh
a genius inventor buys his own island
and then creates some microorganisms and
subjects them to really really harsh
conditions so they evolve really quickly
and and develop intelligence and then he
makes them invent things for them and he
sells them to the rest of the world and
becomes rich and
complications ensue but i'm just saying
i'm just saying that you know if this
academic thing doesn't work out for you
there might be another way to you know
earn a living might take it might take a
few more transfers well yeah because it
does so i mean it's pretty rapid your
your evolution but it's not it's very
fast that rapid i mean but it's still
you know generations several generations
per day not a million generations per
day yeah we're getting five generations
a day and you know
it's frustrating because it's it's a log
of
of the of the you know numerical number
increase so you have these 100 fold
expansions of population size a day and
that's you know six and six and three
quarters generations and it's not even
really hundredfold it's like sixty-four
well but it goes that many generations
it goes back to my my point that um
physicists would be puzzled by how
something that has a time scale measured
in minutes or hours
can change over a time scale of a
billion years in a profound way
but of course
the reason why if you forced a physicist
at gunpoint to say how could that happen
well there must be you know the time the
billion year time scale must be
the small time scale times a big number
a big dimensionless number right and and
that big dimensionless number has must
have to do with
the space of possibilities for these
genomes to evolve right which is just
huge there's a whole bunch of different
mutations that could go on so
i mean how do you i guess in in part
you're dealing with that just by making
the environment really harsh and
therefore you know nudging them to
evolve quickly um but is there some
how do you deal with the fact that even
though you're doing a lot of
generations it's nothing compared to a
billion years worth of evolution
so yeah so we can do some cool tricks uh
to get around some of these things which
is we can we can use synthetic biology
tools to bring in features that evolved
over millions of years and see what they
do in our system which is really fun
so
for example tony brunetti a postdoc in
our group who is a synthetic biology
whiz
has been basically engineering our yeast
to express myoglobin which is an oxygen
binding molecule
and we actually took the sequence
from a sperm whale we optimized it to be
expressed in yeast stuck it into yeast
and it works
they're making sperm whale myoglobin
they're pink they're pink east
and so you know
we basically think that these oxygen
binding molecules their whole thing is
not like holding on oxygen as a battery
it's to increase the diffusion rate of
oxygen through a tissue
and
so we can we can test the hypothesis
that that increasing diffusion rates of
oxygen through a tissue would interact
synergistically over evolutionary time
to drive something to become bigger by
removing constraints of size that are
associated with oxygen
and sure enough that's that's what it
appears to be doing i mean these papers
are not out yet this is work that's
ongoing but you know we took
we took a myoglobin from uh
from a sperm whale
myohemorethrin from a peanut worm which
lives in deep sea sediments and has a
very low oxygen environment and then we
actually took a there's a published
paper from joe thornton's group where
they they use ancestral sequence
reconstruction to identify the
the ancestor of uh myoglobin and
hemoglobin so you know we made that gene
too
so you know so it's not just
sitting around twiddling your thumbs
waiting for evolution to happen in in
the test tubes you're sometimes taking
an active role and poking at it and
seeing what can happen
absolutely yeah there's actually a whole
lot more crazy synthetic biology that
tony's up to um
i could i could tell you if you're
interested
yeah but i ca but i kind of also want to
get back to the to the physics of this
i'm sorry yeah i never really went down
that path got off that uh off that trail
but yes let's complete the physics
discussion okay so um
so initially what all of our
yeasts that are evolving to become
macroscopic do is they make more and
more elongate cells and we really
understand how this affects size and
and uh by affecting the the
essentially the amount of free space
around individual cells and the amount
of jamming that occurs inside a cluster
if you imagine before that you were
building a snowflake east by adding ping
pong balls onto it onto the tree of ping
pong balls you can see that would get
very dense very quickly it would kind of
jam and break apart
but now imagine you're doing the same
thing with hot dogs you have you know
the same group has a lot more free space
it's a lot more fluffy and as a result
you don't have as much jamming and and
when they do finely jam they're at a
much much larger size so all of our
replicate populations are basically
getting mutations which increase the
length of cells which increases group
size and this slowly you know this this
increase in group size is fairly slow
over several hundred generations we're
getting you know ten fold increase in
size and then we see this surprising
break from the sort of linear march
towards slightly increased size we see
things that are
orders of magnitude bigger
with just a little bit more
cell length
and if we in fact look at how these
things are packing normally we expect
them that more elongate cells are
fluffier and is less densely packed
but if you make these things have
slightly longer cells then all of a
sudden they're packing more and more
densely within these clusters which is
not what we expect based on sort of
physical first principles
and so it turns out what's happening is
we're having this shift which in fact if
you're into phase transitions i think
this is something which probably is one
sounds like working on this to know if
it really is we see this shift from
cells being basically
branches on a tree that if you break a
single cell the entire branch falls away
to cells being entangled like vines such
that the cells wrap around adjacent
cells and now if you want to move that
one cell then you're moving its
entangled components and it's and its
entangled components entangle components
and it turns out that that entanglement
percolates throughout the entire cluster
and these groups become orders of
magnitude more tough in fact if you look
at the materials property of them they
go from being a hundred times weaker
than gelatin in as the ancestral
snowflake yeast if you break a single
cell cell bond the material breaks apart
which is great for getting a life cycle
but very bad for making a tough organism
you go from 100 times weaker than
gelatin to snowflake keys that are as
tough and strong as wood
and it's like a cord that is made from
you know wrapping thread you know
various strands of thread yeah
exactly and is that primarily or is this
an answerable question is that primarily
because of the configuration space in
some physics or is it because you're
selecting for bigness and toughness and
and
the yeast discovered how to do that in a
new way
i think it's the latter
but i'd like to talk to peter younger
and my physics collaborator more to to
be sure he sees it the same way i do but
we are providing a massive you know
fitness incentive to get big and out
compete your competitors if you get big
and these things that are entangled are
you know
a thousand times bigger than anything
that came before them like they're
humongous
are you gonna have to increase the size
of your test tubes at some point or
they're gonna become too big your yeast
i don't i
i doubt it um because and there's a
reason baked into the way that we
transfer them we don't actually let the
entire test tube compete to settle at
the end of every day we sub-sample 10 of
it and those yeasts compete to be
transferred so they actually have a 90
chance of dying without ever even having
a chance to compete for faster settling
and that i think actually sets a sort of
maximum size which they can grow before
dilution just kind of gets gets the
better of them
which and actually that's very important
because something which was able to
grow forever would actually be a very
boring organism it would probably kind
of break our system we want things that
actually reproduce and die
yeah yes and we kind of enforce that
through this mechanism okay
so but getting back to phase transitions
i think that this this is something
we're working on but i think that this
entanglement idea is probably an example
of a phase transition that as soon as
something has the potential to entangle
its neighbors that percolates throughout
the entire cluster and you go from
something where you're one fracture away
from from reproduction to having to
break hundreds of bonds and there's not
very much in middle ground
and it sounds like um
something that is actually taking
advantage of the feature of
multicellularity you know it's not just
getting bigger by adding more cells it's
getting a good survival characteristic
by doing something that a multicellular
organism can do that a unicellular
organism can't
that's right and in fact if you look we
spend a lot of time thinking about
entanglement in biology and it turns out
it's a relatively understudied research
area
but if you look at the largest fungi
that have ever existed
there's something called prototaxids a
fungus from the devonian 400ish million
years ago that formed these three foot
tall 20 sorry three foot wide 25 foot
tall columns of fungal mycelium
and
if you look at and they're fossilized so
well you can take thin sections of them
and look at them and you see i mean
they're beautifully entangled the hyphae
are basically going in in two different
directions they're wrapping around each
other it's it's gorgeous
um
and actually as
peter and myself and and perhaps david
who as well who's uh who's at georgia
tech and works on the mechanics of
biology
we're beginning to think more about like
how prevalent is entanglement actually
in biological systems you know for
example is rhino horn an example of a
good example of an entangled material
it's made from hair that's kind of all
meshed up and matted down in this horn
and those hairs are not just like
perfectly parallel so you know how much
is entanglement actually underlying a
lot of the materials properties of
multicellular organisms but we don't
typically think of it that way because
you know they have glue
or you know they have bonds between
cells or something like that but it's
it's clearly you know a nice way uh
that
the possibility of cooperative behavior
is changing the qualitative features of
the organism right
that's right and so getting back to
something you said earlier the way we
introduced talking about the
multicellularity long-term evolution
experiment was are we going to see
cellular differentiation right when are
we going to see cells performing
different things
and we're actually investigating this in
the context of entanglement right now
in the sense that
our yeast cells are all genetically the
same but that does not mean that they're
physiologically the same in fact we see
big differences in in evolved
differences that have evolved over our
experiment in the behavior of young
cells that are sort of
weighted towards the surface
and older cells that are in on the
interior of the cluster it turns out
that older cells are much more likely to
divide from the middle of the cell
making a right angled branch which is
something which drives entanglement new
cells young cells first generation cells
are much more likely to be popped off
the tip of the cells
and in fact it looks like this is
to some extent being coordinated by
changes in the expression of chaperone
proteins which which is which which have
a very broad role in the cell but if we
play with the expression of these
chaperone proteins we can actually
change these phenotypes so we and so
basically what we see is that over
cellular age these things are growing
outwards so the internal cells are old
the external cells are young we're
seeing the evolution of new
age-dependent cellular behaviors which
may be in fact
important for driving the entangled
entanglement phenotype and giving these
groups really robust uh materials
properties well and also an example
yeah is it too much to say like this
this could be the hint of the beginning
of true cellular differentiation and
expression yeah that's exactly how we
are thinking of it is that it's sort of
like if they don't have um
this is one way to get this right like
there is a reliable distribution of like
age provides a reliable signal for where
the cell is if it's young it's probably
on the outside if it's old it's probably
on the inside and we know that yeast
actually have all these things that are
that are expressed differently in age
already so that's actually a lever
that's easy for them to pull and what we
seem to be seeing is them pulling on
this lever of changing the expression of
this chaperone protein which changes
with the distribution of budding which
then changes how entanglement proceeds
that's pretty amazing
that's pretty cool yeah and the most
amazing thing is that you're not taking
billions of years to see it happen by
just nudging it a little bit you're able
to see it uh in the lifetime of a
postdoc
yeah that's right and and the other
thing that's really cool from my
perspective is that a lot of this stuff
is stuff that i would never have been
able to predict before doing the
experiment you know a lot of experiments
in biology are hypothesis driven where
you already have a pretty good idea of
the way the system works before you even
propose the experiment you set it all up
to usually test some very low
dimensional
linear effect
and you know and like
ignoring all the complications of the
real world and you know is this additive
effect significant yes it is
and those experiments are great don't
get me wrong but they're also limiting
and that you have to already kind of
understand your system well enough to be
able to propose that kind of experiment
before you can do it and in our case one
of the beautiful and fun things about
experimental evolution is that
you don't actually necessarily have to
know what you're going to get and you
can be really surprised by the the
twists and turns that your system goes
on well i think that is the perfect
place uh to draw this to a close because
you've given us an enormous amount to
think about and
that's what science is all about being a
little bit surprised about what you
learn and you know i'm hoping that your
experiment goes on for at least 30 years
i think you're being uh modest and it
could be at least 300 years you never
know
that'd be awesome
i will happily hand the reins over to to
someone else well unless they solve
aging by then you can still be the boss
you know for the next 300 years i don't
know oh yes that sounds horrible no no
in fact maybe even a better thing would
be to encourage other people to start
their own you know uh forks we could
also do that oh that's really that's
true i was going to say their own
experiments but of course we can share
right you can you can pass the east
around and uh have it evolved
differently in different
labs that sounds good to me all right
good a project out there for some of the
folks listening to the weinstein podcast
so real quick radcliff thanks so much
for being on mindscape thank you so much
i had a great time
[Music]
you